last question today from Surrey D Surrey
D says David can any Democrats other
than the big three still make a comeback
okay
so this sort of relates to the last
question as of the taping right now of
this question
Biden's polling 29 Sanders is polling 17
Warren 16.3 a pretty significant gap has
now developed between the top three
Biden Sanders and Warren and everybody
else in fourth place right now is Kamala
Harris at 7 feet Buddha judges at four
and a half and then you've got Andrew
yang at 2 and a half and Booker at 2.40
Roark at 2.4 so III think that at this
point the only person who maybe has a
shot is Kamala Harris but if I really
just think about it I don't really think
she has a shot I think it is Biden
Sanders or Warren Joe Sestak is polling
0 Delaney 0.1 Gillibrand 0.1 she's out
Tim Ryan I think is that I don't even
remember who's in or out but I mean a
lot of these people aren't even polling
1% stired de Blasio Marianne Williamson
Bullock Klobuchar they're all under 1%
they have no shot Cooley on Castro at
1.1 I don't see a path for him Tulsi
Gabbard at 1.4 she's not even in the
third debate she has no chance
bata or Rourke and Cory Booker both at
2.4 percent at one point they were
considered serious candidates I don't
see any path for them Andrew yang at 2.5
again I don't I said it in the last
question I don't see how he breaks
through 5% Pete Buddha judge at 4.6 to
even be taken seriously he's got to at
least get to where Kamala Harris's maybe
it'll happen after debate number three
so then you've got Kamala Harris at 7
she is at less than half the support of
Elizabeth Warren could she again have
such a brutal takedown of Joe Biden in
the third debate that she pops four
points and gets close to Elizabeth
Warren it's possible but we're only four
or five months at this point from the
first votes and there is no trend line
that shows her benefiting in any
significant way
from anything that she's doing right now
so I think it's down to Biden Warren and
Sanders there is this question if
Sanders leaves does it make war in the
the favorite if Warren leaves does it
make Bernie the favorite I know a lot of
people think the answer is obviously yes
when you look at the second choice for
each of them
the second choice were a plurality of
Warren voters is Kamala Harris the
second choice for a plurality of Bernie
voters is Joe Biden so it is not as
obvious to me that if one of them Bernie
or Warren Bale all of their support goes
to the other and they surpassed Joe
Biden the polling doesn't suggest that
at least as of right now we will see
what polling continues to say but I
think this is down to the big three at
this point if you have either number one
historical evidence for when someone
outside the top three in September of
the year before ended up winning send it
to me I want to see that polling data if
you have a narrative of how someone
outside of the top three could end up
winning this nomination write to me and
tell me how for example kamala will do
so well in debate three that you'll get
to 11% and then Elizabeth Warren will
have some problem and a lot of Warren
voters would go to Harris and then that
will put Harris in contention with
Bernie and right I mean give me the
story of how you think it will happen I
just simply don't see it we've got a
great bonus show for you today we will
talk about the world's longest cruise
setting sail from London it is my worst
nightmare someone who gets seasick we
will talk about a First Amendment group
asking a OC to unblock users on Twitter
and we will also talk about Bernie
Sanders previewing a plan to cancel all
past due medical debt we will talk about
the finances of it and the politics of
it but it will be on the bonus show
become a member or a patron to access
the bonus show at join pakman.com or
patreon.com slash david pakman show